des rues quasi désertes et des commerces
fermés
le centre ville habituellement bondées
ressemble presque à une ville fantôme
commune voisine de mulhouse colmar a dû
faire face à l'afflux des malades du
coronavirus les habitants qui n'ont pas
été infectés n'ont qu'un seul mot à la
bouche confinement c'est clair il faut
que tout le monde reste chez soi c'est
saturation partout et si les gens ne
comprennent pas ça on n'arrivera jamais
à arrêter l'épidémie faut vraiment que
les gens passent serviront tout le monde
est à la maison sang organise une sortie
par semaine pour les courses et voilà
c'est nous on est dans une maison avec
un jardin donc c'est plus facile que les
gens qui sont inversement
je fais mon petit toujours une heure par
jour mais rapidement sont croisés
personnes sont serrés les vraiment
souffert les visent mais ça se passe
bien point ce qu'il faut vraiment rester
chez soi et au moins on contient
contaminera plus personne quant au moins
que ça se finisse rapidement quand il se
reprend une vie normale pour d'autres
avec le retour à une vie normale sonnera
aussi l'heure des responsabilités pour
chacun y compris celle de l'êta que le
président trouve qu'il a trouvée il
faudra qu'il trouve des solutions un
même qui les a pris tardivement
maintenant les dispositions à lui de
remettre tout en ordre
il est président pour ça il est
président pour les français il est
président pour nous aider pour quand
même faire confiance même si on peut
toujours avoir des griefs contre les
gens qui nous dirigent mais je pense
qu'il faut leur faire confiance ils
prennent les choses à bras le corps et
et
il faut les écouter toute façon on n'a
pas trop le choix et puis fera les
comptes à la fin je faisais des services
soignants aussi à s'en sortir le plus
vite je pense que et surtout ici d'un
grand test tous ceux qui le milieu
hospitalisés hospitalier de colmar et de
strasbourg et de mulhouse pour un
travail de dingue donc c'est la moindre
des choses
les adhérents sont sera dans les trois
hôpitaux de colmar les services
d'urgence sont proches de la rupture
face à l'afflux de malades incessants
c'est très important et il est
indispensable vraiment que la population
suivre les consignes strictes de
confinement parce que le virus se
propage de manière très très très
contagieuse j'estime qu'il ya c'est la
seule solution pour éviter la
propagation du virus
et vous connaissez la situation
compliquée aujourd'hui est même
dramatique dans le département du haut
rhin
je lance un appel ou aux alsaciens aux
français pour qu'ils restent chez eux on
a besoin que l'état nous aide nous
envoie des personnels des personnels
soignants et qui nous envoie du matériel
qui nous envoient des respirateurs qui
nous envoient des masques pour protéger
nos soignants et pour essayer de sauver
un maximum de vies
le département du haut rhin est à ce
jour celui qui recense le plus de morts
en france
alors à colmar comme ailleurs on attend
avec impatience la fin de l'épidémie